would you rather give up the hungover  breakfast sandwich or the drunk pizza um  that's tough  i'd have to give up the  hungover i don't have to give up the  drunk pizza because when i was like oh  because i'm hammered i don't want  anything to mess up that buzz i just  want to crash out and i wake up hungry  and so i don't have to give that up i  don't want to sweep myself up no no i  want to stay i want to stay up cause  then you sleep better wait because i  when i eat after i've been drinking i  feel my stomach feels all [ __ ] like  you know then you're like murdering  toilets and stuff that's not that's  you don't want i'd rather not give up  that yeah you get all you get all tore  up and you're all tore up the next day